and where there are nerd fans there are  nerd tattoos and I believe you you've  had your first nerd tattooed yes yes I  came across um I am a Oh Jess you have  had the character of gin tattooed onto  his you are you he said you tattoo what  yeah I guess  meet me at me I've been tattooed onto  his car what really worried for a second  he's got a big cut yeah I know we've got  a picture of a dog I don't think we can  show that  here's anyone here on a class oh my  goodness oh man  OSE there's his ankles okay so they're  easy it's actually kind of an oddly good  likeness for a tattoo  yeah I'm just worried about what happens  when the hair grows back I'm gonna be a  big lady Planet of the Apes now Graham  Norton here if you'd like to see even  more stuff like that then hit subscribe  or don't it's a free world but I know  what I do in that situation